so what you're saying is you're not
gonna help Griffin what kills help or
get all the [ __ ] pills gonna be a
team player
how am i how am I I think it's okay hold
on Pikachu you should go to them and
we'll take we'll take you there Griffin
there Boulder you should take it over
mm-hmm Boulder switch switch to us okay
that's fine you're free on coke steam so
then when costa's Griffin's killed
Griffin can call him out perfect oh my
kill again
yeah and what he does is he doesn't save
you you like hi Dan don't ya don't
[ __ ] yell I don't see a bowl I hate
it I hate to tell you guys but when I
got three terrible people on my team and
I'm going against four other people that
are competent I can't take out all four
instantly what the snap of my Thanos
[ __ ] infinity stone I don't even
think that's what he was wearing the
Infinity Gauntlet
just anomalous yeah yeah you got it
didn't you you [ __ ] got it you
understood what I was talking about all
right so what you're saying is you're
not gonna help Griffin what kills help
or me get all the [ __ ] pills
it's be heard they're not gonna be a
team player
how am i how am I not as home tonight
I'll be Brian on our team I'm so glad
you guys are out the safe room makes it
so much better all right the next one I
get to shoot Griffin in the face he's
moving and [ __ ] boot camp wore me out
today I tell you I've heard times I'm
Vito whenever the whenever there's a
break a break in the [ __ ]
conversation Craig will just recycle
something he said earlier you notice
that you notice that he does it all the
time if we stop talking for the
environment you go oh my god I can't
wait till Trump's impeached you know he
tries to get these conversations
starters look and I'll be I'll be dead
silent I won't respond to any of them
and he'll just be like you're there
you're there hello rage mode flash all
those protein shake sorry Craig
that's what you're saying the muscle
milk muscle milk extra actually that
[ __ ] was good though
oh this man I got you hooked huh that's
fun let's follow me yeah you did well it
helps right after working out
but the muscle milk yeah that's for
quicker recovery holy where are you
going homie what are you doing hey I
said follow him follow me
Jesus Christ dude
thanks a lot owe me I'm glad you're on
our team [ __ ] hell I can't believe I
[ __ ] up my grenade I can't believe I
owe me just decided to give us a little
loss already thanks only what the [ __ ]
is that you're not helping the team or
to God last [ __ ] side all right
traded trade it sent us on the board
okay let's go this gospel
oh oh oh you owe me what the [ __ ] is
that what you did the tractor cannon
shotgun nonsense
thank you thank you for your [ __ ] I
almost killed Steve what's your
resilient life kill squishy ass plug
just lucky that was great that was C
[ __ ] I need help
I saw me ah
what
oh my I saw you with it - I saw you hold
they're gonna call me behind us coming
around God that was a spawn kill dude I
just came around that corner
[ __ ] [ __ ] that gun hey drop it
you just stole my [ __ ] kill that was
a kill seal hey
something weighty to say and it's just
now that sometimes they had only wasn't
dropping off the map angry reaction it
was like three minutes at ok oh my god
ah make sure you got that that's out in
the open
boys they show you how many times you
kill a person cuz that'd be great
I would that would be fast alerts that
would be cool
you can hold start can't you damn it mr.
Machado go I missed my shot should have
killed you actually yeah I felt like you
actually could have there to you because
I popped it too far back flanking you
you think you're gonna get heavy you I
know
oh we missed it wow that did not you
been wow those balls were useless
Oh me okay okay
let's call me this sleeper I'm like so
happy yes oh you where are you buddy I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna scream okay coke
just got sleeper I'm not running anymore
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh you know you just said you weren't
get him on me go get him all weekend
and come on Craig shoot me Jesus Christ
I should have been dead what are we
playing a 45-minute game
it's just 13 minutes Jesus man right
we've got our 250 right you know homies
tired we got to draw it out make him
play as much as he doesn't want it
that's smart
god damn it sorry Griffin
you just you're just useless what was
that about
how's the kid you got lucky we're all
together I got looking at on huh yeah we
were together oh [ __ ] sleeper simulant I
hate that [ __ ] thing such a [ __ ]
people just keep camping Craig gets a
free kill I'm not camping you [ __ ] on
Bobo
those two were shooting me on the side
yeah you can't be doing that a whole new
team shoot all these what do you owe me
help us out talk to us bro what's going
on good really good
get good well this [ __ ] you know
what I agree good good how are you not
dead are you guys in a rift like what's
going on yeah
goddammit obviously someone got right in
the way migrant [ __ ] throwing knife
nice homey does that sleeper does that
sleeper get your shield back when you
hit what no I'm telling you I use my
melee combo so I get my own shield okay
because I was like damn you got your
shoe back everybody else you play again
[ __ ] such a [ __ ] [ __ ] weapon no
the good farm come on yeah I was
shooting the other way yes so [ __ ]
tired again that
Oh hold on Obama Griffen Griffen Griffen
get them Cal huh
Griffin got away lucky house closed up
I almost got ya sure was it sure was
damn the traffic I didn't know they're
all there
I can't I'm gonna run out we trails [ __ ]
your [ __ ] I got hello took your gold
and uh I gotta sign up you're going get
him get it off me
hope you're not gonna kill me I'm
killing myself oh wow how did you
survive that cuz I'm a [ __ ] beast
Christ could ask some question to your
left left
yeah oh [ __ ] I saw him jump up I wanted
to do a team line my back only they're
both there there before doorway gone I
only get one shot of that no - - and
it's like an immediate murder
[Laughter]
lted by your [ __ ] sleeper simulant
literally check it out 19 kills wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute you
don't want me to use my sleeper and you
think you're gonna beat me did I hear
that right
I think what that's three I think with
us three and no sleep for you okay
alright alright okay here I'll get heavy
let's not do heavy let's not do have you
this round I don't like how this is
turning out there no he's like I don't
want to be on that team anymore no no no
wait what's going on Oh me get back here
[Laughter]
let's go wait what's that
I know me verse off word are we doing
heavier no hair then I'll tell you what
you can use heavy dealer's choice for
you use heavy he's just gonna rack up
multiple kills on us well he only shot a
bit yeah we'll do this one no you can
you guys can use heavy
if worried isn't heavy you guys yeah go
ahead yeah that's time Sam
give me beer sure honey
[ __ ] I like my [ __ ] great thanks said
yeah it's like the news [ __ ] that's the
three new expansion ship it looks like a
jet yeah I like the look that was the
worst I did all night of course not over
recording [ __ ] great I swear to God
every time I saw coke he was just simply
pursue me a [ __ ] sign he never he hit
me like seriously I'm not joking like
90% of my desk were from his sleeper I
do that's heaven and do some holes how
many how many sleeper cell hits teeth
take you killed so many bro
at least ten literally I come around I
see him with that [ __ ] and then there's
nothing I could do he doesn't [ __ ]
move
he's just like you know I came at you
but you had your [ __ ] own TVs
megaweapon you were using keep yourself
you're stealing my castle
Oh cooks oh he's over there you go I'll
get his ass let's go let's go yeah good
job guys keep [ __ ] him up take him to
the hole since Jason ghoul murder him
together deep shot he's going for a
sleeper simulant there is right there
we're still losing guys I know that cuz
of me oh my god every time he dies every
time he dies an angel gets their wings
let's go Peaks nice night shooting good
team shooting Peaks no let's see here
coke I mean he's trying to get serious
about it okay serious four [ __ ]
people you [ __ ]
yeah no I'm not I'm not a this is I'm so
gonna [ __ ] mercy
that damn it my [ __ ] controller died
in mid-battle that's called karma this
is how he killed me every time [ __ ]
sleeper simulant
he's going back for more I hate you
she's the only dude that has it to that
we know oh my god that was annoying
teabag teabag teabag oh me oh me okay I
was gonna save him the flowers okay
let's follow the float for mob yeah form
up let's not run around with our heads
cut off
you know Wonder Twins all of a sudden
how did that not catch you that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] nice riff Wow oh my god
yeah the sleeper how do you like a
Pikachu it's a lot of fun huh
how do you like that killed him okay you
wanna dance now how are using so badly
19 to 8 kill him
oh you have eight shots on that [ __ ]
thing Thanks
pause okay let's we need to form up guys
you guys are all running in where are
you if you believe Lee yeah let's go
behind you guys right now
shoot coke we got him chase him come on
guys good job alright stay together
let's stay together
geeks go follow you damn I got a viewers
right now where the [ __ ] are you there
in person good job Oh flanking just
melted are you [ __ ] him how the [ __ ]
you survived that what were you oh oh me
just like turns it on the ball or are
you wearing Oh me you have like some
special [ __ ] on cuz like that was
ridiculous
no I'll say no run run
good to know homies a piece of that
thank you I still understand how you do
not something diet and walking through
right [ __ ] that made no sense because I
know how that's the colony that's why
so a noise spread out [ __ ] real
weapon alright we're not that far behind
guys I don't understand why we're this
far behind in the first place
well there's nobody behind and you noble
bomb that he was so he was so [ __ ]
hurt trade in I stopped shooting mid
shooting it's only much floss who took
that you could have it let's go let's go
we can catch up let's catch up let's
work together good race
outside he ran away alright JD to Drew
deserted there we go nice Walter yeah
there we good now we got a groove champ
I'm loving any DLC man the grind is back
and destiny - don't let him get that
heavy don't let me get the happy
hey go Bolger we're catching up work
together not like it do not let cook get
sleep or cinema and I know my pain
they're all there just go up and over to
see them on the screen
ah yeah got you over there back to
Griffin folks over there
run iron
you don't get them nice I guess bandit
getting it you're gonna go for the other
one quick let's stop let's stop him get
to the heavy they got it
they're good they got it vulgar said
what made you miss one thing I made you
miss one that's all I care about you
know if you had a dodge though like as a
hunter I'd be great for that gun if you
knew he had at least lost on t-bag Oh
cook Thomas hurt oh nice pika get them
nice pika
good job pika
guys come get this riff that heavy yeah
coming to you Griffin hold out there you
go Peaks you got the other one oh my god
he's gonna get the heavy [ __ ] we're down
by 16 boys oh [ __ ] coke it's alright
I got it
see this is the [ __ ] I'm talking about I
have to waste you know my [ __ ] to murder
you you weren't even close you did that
so far away and nobody well my point is
like I can't all these uses suppressor
grenades yeah that bastard yep that's
all he does
we're not gonna catch out we started to
catch up though I started to play better
oh wow it wasit well Steve Griffin do
better than Craig oh you mean maybe my
KD my case yeah Oh either bad both of us
peak so you should you shouldn't watch
the truth anyone watch what you're
saying
I didn't more damage than that everybody
that's know whatever escalation protocol
we tried it man this is [ __ ] hard
though I I've only got past the first
wave on the first series ah [ __ ] me that
escalation man you know you know it goes
seven levels oh [ __ ] yeah oh we're
playing rumble
we're doing Rumble
lady Robin ballroom that doesn't make
any sense
come on shoot me a coke yeah there it is
go for it
well we traded you and your [ __ ]
it's sleeper hate that thing you're the
only dude that has it I'm the only guy
Crucible even really using it and I
haven't seen anybody else using it I
know that's true hi Kirk right Rick yeah
you got me you got me you got me see Sam
hoger see he's going for it
switch guy
oh are you still how'd you get it again
we're [ __ ] and then you ran away son
of a [ __ ]
I was like one butchered little breath I
know what you were oh how you survived
that down oh I did either
yeah that's great okay [ __ ] you get to
point-blank range
yeah yeah man so tired of you with that
gun thanks Walter
yeah you know I'm going for a coke he's
kind of on the top of a leaderboard
there Thanks oh sorry yeah but he get I
saw you so he just points any stole come
on Tommy now that makes sense to do
Rumble with Pikachu also bring its back
oh yeah for sir that was the plan go
kiting okay we don't I don't see anybody
goddammit
older why didn't you play like this when
I played every other game no I was doing
stuff earlier big stuff on my phone
ah well that one killed mine delete oh
you got huh yeah we traded yeah I want
to do over we don't get [ __ ] sleeper
good that's 90% I'll coax kill me now
golden come and you always [ __ ] the one
I just go get heavy you're such a I'm
moving I'm getting kills I'm getting
kills are not getting killed so yeah
blah blah but when I get heavy and kill
you you wait by heavy I'm moving I'm
moving across the map the entire time
there's craig running
oh how are you still alive yes I got
Craig corpse win it so it doesn't matter
if you kill me you gotta kill the guys
as women I not hard to miss Craig with
those why do you run through that I know
but when you go through my shield it
takes off power damage don't see the
light upper cut through the thing it's
not Street Fighter
go get them get them Jason you got
you're the king
- you haven't go I just hope I was about
to dance yeah I got you that time
Craig Scott Rockets and he wasted
get up killing kill always selling hurt
we're tied
oh [ __ ] we just get somebody
yes good oh good you're supposed to be
dead God dang it where's coke waiting by
heavy sumbitch that's what you do do not
Oh Craig that's what you get it okay
god damn it you [ __ ] I knew you were
just waiting over there buddy you're
such a [ __ ] Naha hate you hate you
with that [ __ ] gun it's impossible I
hope people on Twitch watch this so they
know that's everybody just started using
that [ __ ] be [ __ ] like you it's my
fault that we both died yeah it is like
a little coward guy Hey look that's way
our souls are useless
hmm cuz like you take away power you use
our nah they just they don't uh like
they're not fast so like get strafing
it's hard to hate it only hit [ __ ]
that's like Scott my dad he should have
cared
I died right over there there's crew
like yeah they don't shoot they're not
shooting fast enough to be useful good
coke he's the one winning what we can't
catch up to it's okay you said how are
you every time what the hell
every [ __ ] time he's got super
stimulant ammo [ __ ] god again I know
that's what I'm saying he killed himself
not a team player
no ideas you're supposed to call the guy
in the top of the ladder I'm just
killing whoever gets in my way
hooting yourself yeah I just killed
myself right there it's how we traded
look out of here man how long is this
game you put this number 49 to 25 kills
out 25
oh man kills me
good job sleeper simulant you should go
work for that group what everybody wants
a word for everything it's safe to say
Craig hates the sleepers are you gonna
use this one to get it if I ever get it
I'm gonna [ __ ] close fix forever how
much how many questions you have to do
it's like 17 five five steps
yeah ah they're dry no they're long
they're drying on the other grinders
more speed to still tagging off what
should we do you three but you 3 first
mate I'm down to try it through your own
one they're yelling we just did that
no no engaged four-on-two no suite for
Craig okay going
seriously cook is this even like a
challenge
dude one verse three will always always
be a challenge doesn't matter how good
the person isn't like and wow you're
making me blush
she's so kind now am I still gonna [ __ ]
someone up get it yep yes did I manage
to get the exotic sword yet that's it
yeah that's a grind - I really don't
want it
oh you stored so much boy looks cool Oh
what about if we do one less three
against cut that's why I just said yeah
yeah yeah we're gonna do it um I tell
Pathak aleinu what you're doing go
further this will be challenging man
destiny choose not destiny one that's uh
destiny one the like the matchups are
like the time to kill was is small us
and I can kill and get away as long as
we don't let him get sleeper simulant I
just want to go back to Bungie to tell
him like hey give me back my money for
Christmas Cyrus it's that was
disappointing yeah the war mines way
better yeah like they totally redid
everything what that music they had
things were done I mean ever kind of
stuff yeah yeah well they stole what how
many more years they got left on the
country this is the weirdest texture
this Pikachu says ready for the Pikachu
text got a headache got a headache
taking a shower he playing without me
I think he's gonna rub one out I think
that's what he's going to do he does
weird stuff like that sometimes like we
has a headache he takes a shower I'm
like what is that gonna do that might
help actually water is very Ely it is
actually you know what you know but he
needs to like drink some caffeine have
the blood flow
it helps you should stick together you
don't need to worry and we got this
whose backpack I got it is
oh come on how did that kill them please
[ __ ] ran away what he can't keep up I
had him so low there go go go go
push push push
oh my god thank you I haven't I seen him
one time I don't know where you are
you're like on the other side of the map
yeah get the heavy heavy this one
get the other one get this heavy he's
getting the other my god you guys here
we go here we go here we go
that rocket no way God I jumped way
before that how do you know it honestly
I'll give up Craig he's actually pretty
damn good to Rockets
how are you bad with rockets this is the
question I just premature I just shoot
what are we guys what are you guys doing
back here Griffin what are you doing
above the heavy he's about to get the
other happy yes just mind your business
[Laughter]
ah get up we're never what you guys
Jesus now you get up now you get off him
oh my god
now you came to night I just dropped a
hole shits on the heavy so I had nine I
had nine ogre get to have you get the
heavy get Sammy get the heavy find you
well if he wins this is cuz we're just
playing dumb I mean I don't even know I
mean Jesus there's more chance for him
to get that's the other thing too though
yeah he's getting hurt we're not cut a
crowd team shooting that's the real
problem to know where this [ __ ] is yes
there you know that's nice good job
I wanna get this heavy get the heavy
inside there Boulder Boulder behind you
okay no Griffin it's good no all right
somebody get it I just don't want this
dude grabbing it cuz he'll get those two
kills how high that was great Boulder
how I feel beautiful
thank you I feel proud of myself
actually got two hits here no you sure
that that that I don't know usually
that's a killer I don't know why I
didn't do as much damage I don't know to
be honest you should have killed me
there I agree I don't like to agree with
you but I I do there
he's hurt where is everybody really
where is everybody I hit him with a
grenade
nobody's getting heavy he's game too
heavy trying to hit me now Paul are you
at
goddammit Oh hit me now I'm trying to
get him out nobody kill him this is
weird
we're just bad Jeremy like we need to
Facebook back that's [ __ ] dude you
shot me behind the wall we have to work
together can we [ __ ] move together
let's just move yeah yeah I'm engaging
on them where were you I was right
behind you but it didn't help us
sleeping yeah get these heavier get
these heavy yeah I got that's all I'm
going I know where this [ __ ]
gonna go all right now get back together
so we're [ __ ] together it's not this
great but Instagram thing it says like
I'm old enough to remember when the
hashtag used to be called it a pound Oh
like hashtag me to is pound me - that's
her a funny push push push push
he's running he's running yeah he's
right
I got a [ __ ] see he's just along
together we just run together just run
together cousin he's worked Braun
defeatable he's gonna go for this other
heavy over here yeah but the problem is
we gotta kill him six more times to
catch up so we can kill him he's gonna
go for the other heavy mm-hmm I see
where he's running to he's got it
no he doesn't you're dead
calling who's gonna call him don't give
up what we're doing come on man
I catch up we can hear it
yeah there we go that's what I'm talking
about
team shooting is real team shooting is
real four more kills one more kills to
catch up yeah go to that one go to that
one I'm gonna hold back here and away
thank you oh we get it we're gonna we
gotta catch up I just shot one too
get that heavy
where is this [ __ ] it's gonna get too
heavy you guys get too heavy probably
went to the other one damn cool all
right
catching up throw the other one go to
the other one he's gonna go there how
can I go there you ever think of that
Wow nice our two blind Wow
Oh burns me give you a head shot
get that gun like a seed market yeah I
get that driven nice
15 seconds on this one i'ma wait it's
coming to you
Crouch someone
oh-ho-ho-ho what you have god damn keep
right on me he's going to the other one
Oh Gary he's what oh yeah a Golden Gun
ah [ __ ] I just said he's going to other
one
yeah Golden Gun there's nothing we could
do there there you go he melted me
he's just waiting there ice cream
can't we gotta get you got it get a get
back there guys come on gotta do this
don't let them beat us like this Emmons
lotta catching up pay for more kills
yeah we keep saying that and then we die
well I didn't die
over here guys there you go maybe we
can't trade damn it yeah yeah well
that's supposed to volker go to that one
I'll stay at this one
see you soon yaar I'll roam in the
middle got it this is it [ __ ]
shooting
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] nope oh there it is
everybody on stream 1 verse 3
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]